[Music]
the world has a way of changing
and we change too i know some people
there are moments that separate us
[Music]
but we always come back together
we heard y'all needed a little love out
here
y'all ever thought about the wild
missions we've been on we've taken out
planes
trains tanks i'm not going to think
about the submarine
[Music]
now we got cars flying in the air
[Music]
who is he jacob is
dom's brother
been a long time dog little brother
you always say never turn your back on
family but you turned your back on me
now your little family is in my world
[Music]
are you ready whatever's
[Music]
so how do y'all want to play this fast
okay this is a bad time to mention this
but i don't drive
brother against brother this should be
interesting
but could you kill him
[Music]
you break
crank it all the way up
it's good to be back no white flag
we supposed to stop that hold on
i spent my entire life in your shadow
and now
you spend the rest of yours
really duct tape you acting like we're
on our way to home depot
i don't wanna die
i used to live my life a quarter mile at
a time
but things changed
oh father now i will always be
in your heart little brian i have a gift
for you
your daddy gave me this no i'm gonna
give it to you
it's very special it's for protection
from what's coming
all right dom what's next
no matter how fast you are
[Music]
and mine just caught up to me
been a long time
so we're up against a master thief
assassin
high performance driver
[Music]
who is he
jacob is dom's brother
your whole life you pushed yourself to
be faster than dawn
smarter than dumb stronger than don
but could you kill him
because i'm ready if you are
there's nothing more powerful than the
lover family but you turn that into
anger there's nothing more dangerous
maybe this is the end but we're gonna go
out together you know i'd ride to the
death with you
[Music]
[Applause]
let's get to work please tell me that's
not a pontiac fiero strapped to a rocket
engine
impressive i know no
no that's that's not impressive
i came here to take you down little
brother that's your mistake
this is my world
[Music]
damn they got a magnet plane hold on
tell me you're not thinking what i think
you're thinking there's no bridge
oh hell no
[Music]
hey guys
surprise nice clubhouse
[Music]
you